la caccia emozione giornalino vuole
mangiare questa ecco perché mi sta
guardando in questo modo ma non posso
dargli altimetria distrugge 33 cosi cosi
line memory challenge de corato abbiamo
già fatto un video slide memory
challenge con le lettere questa volta
però abbiamo i numeri l'altro video
raggiunto tipo i ben di minori piace e
quindi per questa sto facendo il
continuo
lasciate un bel mi piace se volete
vedere altri slam challenge a 10 mila mi
piace trovi un altro atleta lenge così
dice pure che tali challenge potete
vedere nei commenti se sarà un pochino
diversa perchè non potremo scegliere noi
il numero ma dovremo tirare il dado
qualsiasi numero ci capita dovremo
girarlo per primo e poi dovremo
ricordarsi dove la coppia
dell'ingrediente come memory
praticamente se riusciamo a trovare la
coppia giusta possiamo mettere gli
ingredienti del nostro slime se non
riusciamo a trovarla non vinciamo niente
in più ci sarà come sempre la cassettina
sensi capita la cassettina l'altra
persona dovrà decidere cosa mettere
dentro il nostro vivaio
mettetevi comodi in prendete i pop corn
e iniziamo subito la salle
ok vediamo chi inizia carta forbice
sasso carta forbice sascha ruffo
io allora tiro il dado sperando che
berlino 1 mag ha subito ha sgranocchiato
tanto bene ho visto che numero c'era
allora lo stile qua sopra sul letto
numero loro numero uno ok giro la
casella numero uno e poi questo
scegliere l'altro numero berlina cabrio
mio ci posso credere né a casa perde
vabbè tanto sicuramente non troverò mai
la coppia quindi giro un numero a caso
vediamo uno dei miei numeri preferiti i
sette vediamo benissimo 09 beccarti la
coppia e in più ho beccato proprio la
coppia tabacco sulla verde ottimo
perfetto allora prendila con la verga
che cominciamo subito a fare il tuo
slide per la challenge inizia malissimo
in tutte le possibilità che c'erano la
maledizione del verde mi ha perseguitato
berlino già rimischiato tutti i numeri
alla verde si non è quella glitterata
perché quella l'abbiamo ma berlino cosa
stai facendo verbo non è quella
glitterato perché quelle l'abbiamo
finita ma vabbè comunque verde bene sono
sempre superfortunate queste challenge
ecco qua la mia con la verde la mia
solita fortuna cosa è viva maledizione
del verde è sempre presente a mi sono
dimenticata di alla fine del video
dovrete votare se vinco io se vince
evitare in base alla bellezza dello
slide manca 6 iniziando molto valido ho
fatto bellezza davvero stupendo tutti i
pezzi fornire tanque è atteso il
problema allora procureremo che ti
capiti la giacchetta merito al gruppo si
gira a sperare di smangiucchiare il dato
dell'icc a berlino vediamo un po che
sezioni il nord
[Applauso]
come hai fatto tu questa scheda sd le
tre numeri e speriamo che il mio lavoro
fortunato berlino si sta mangiato la
cassetta aspettà perchè prima 8 prodotto
allora vuol dire che la mia teoria che
questa qui non sono vecchiette dei
gelati al cioccolato di presentarmi al
mare che vieta rocco mangiardi amore
milic aspetti da mille ingredienti come
potrei rovinare il tuo slime baby
c'è il matrone mi ricordo memoria del
marrone marrone no no è un po sciolto ma
devo ammettere qualcosa di bruttissimo
cosa fortemente da berlina da lì c'è un
marrone mai metallizzato quindi
diventerebbe solo bello il time e
seconda voce rwc aree di vincere questo
challenge
devo ammettere qualcosa di più magari
qualche cambio di di costanzo ha cercato
problema magari certo chiediamo 4
berlino mazzocchi ha pure quelli rai
quindi saranno due slam fertili beh
dipende da cosa capita dopo però devo
dire che comunque più bello del mio
perché vediamo cosa ci capita adesso
anche i toccamenti l'ha realizzato
vediamo 5
vediamo un po cosa si nasconde dietro il
numero 5 tanta tanta tanta
[Musica]
altra coppia dove potrebbe essere 0 2 3
4 e 9 quelli scegli non so se provare
con un mio altro numero preferito che il
2 ma l'altra volta effetti mi ha portato
sfortuna quindi ma berlino ha forse un
segno forse berlino vuole dirmi che non
devo prendere nelle terne 4 di cibi
berlino quindi sta cercando di indicarmi
il 4 ha nascosto 0 con una zampa
proviamo con il 4 e magari ami non sto
pensando io vedo solo stesso perché ero
stanco dai quattro sono glitter dorati
niente niente toccate in un furbacchione
si è sdraiato sul letto così pensa che
noi andremo a tirare il danieli moderate
vero chiare lo tirerò per terra così lui
salterà subito dietro e non prendere
troppo fatti oggettivi attendevo
spostare il 5 togliti questi titoli di
berlino ti abrams in una cosa c'era
dietro cinque minuti il corriere
rimettendo tutto le palline blu
all'orale se gli inviamo in berlino che
cosa mi consiglia vi consiglio di
prendere fatto non oil 4 l'ha preso
ho preso primari di talco altro che non
segni allora io provo ma vediamo
ti ricordi mai certo che mi ricordo
producono detto mesi diamo attiva io sto
dove sono stato me sono solo nel 5 e
sicura prima di aprirlo mattina abbiamo
parte primerano nel simbolo o nel 4 non
mi vedeva dubbio le rose al 5
io mi ricordo 5 pedina sicura vinto però
fa dove telebani e brunel guerre
bruttissimo almeno diventa pokhran si
diventa un po più carino evasione
diventa un po più blu invece che queste
partite ricordate non ti gira un po sarà
super crunchy non vedo l'ora di
attivarlo peccato che lo verde
quando il suo slam impatto a farlo così
ben sei per caso fischiato perline
colorate verde beh per il momento sono
in vantaggio per architetti numero 43 o
no perché non vorrebbe l'inter perché mi
farò lo slam marrone da te la puoi fare
fitta di prenderne un altro così vedi
cosa c'è dentro così vedo anch'io cosa
certa a dolo guardo solo io no di musica
con la rosa che bene rosa e verde che
col resce fuori brutto non c'è scampo
uscirò monta il bruttissimo almeno
metterei un po di colla fino adesso lo
shampoo e lo faccio con l'acsi giappone
perché a me vediamo duro da una ventina
devo ritirare prati via
sì sì 4
io so già cosa c'è il 4o è finito di
scegliere un altro numero
no perché a me piace ma anche se non so
come diventerà con quello verde così
diventerà ballare era qua nel nome
[Musica]
magari migliore
ecco qua il pigmento dorato vediamo
quanto diventa brutto dobbiamo diventare
marrone devi diventare oro non marrone e
aspetta sta diventando un po
metallizzato guarda il vino e per finire
utilizzata è diventato un po rom è di
meno ma che tiri non è brutto e
bellissimo la bellissima ne pensate è
davvero stupendo il più bello questo
slime rimasti solo due numeri quindi non
c'è bisogno di tirare ritardo ma ti
basta girati e allora io corato ha
capito che mi è uscito il numero zero
con la rosa e 22 ma ammette possono
entrare la colla del mio slime lavoro io
la giornata è invece un peso io e casini
ma per che cosa è uscito bruni che
diventi marrara del patentino ma dona
qualche bella questa cosa che ha voglia
di tornare glitterate stupenda potevo
neanche aggiungere altri ingredienti
perché è già bella così vediamo come
tipico da me uscirà bellissimo secondo
voi che ne pensate
pira media marrone
talento nato rosa marrone marrone dai
verde 800 un sacco di bolle è diventato
d'acqua questo brand celestino grigio
pinot grigio niente fortuna prima siamo
vederli attivati vedere anche subito
bello e grigio bello questo valore è
grigio
andiamo ad attivarle chiamati bene
vediamo come diventano ecco qua il mio
slime allora devo dire che il colore è
un po particolare molto bello non riesco
a capire se un verde on dorato è un vero
tesoro altro dove molto fumo web dai non
è male meglio di un verde normale un
verde dorato verde metallizzato prova
dei missini crunchy sentite un po
[Musica]
che bello lo sly impietrito hanno fatto
perdendo le palline mannaggia dai però
il colore non è così male
dovrà una sorta di vomito si trova
vediamo il tuo guardate e anche su
morbello è già e chuck i glitter
guardate che per colore ma non venne sul
marito colore e argento violaceo è
stupendo guardate che bello.la pochi mi
sa che abbiamo un vincitore che il
vincitore
siamo da lanciano e mi ha lanciato
voglio sentire la cosiddetta setti la
consistenza di questa chiacchierata che
hai fatto tu è invidiosa solo perché io
l'ho fatto meglio e invidiosa guardate
guardate che bella topa bambini beh in
effetti devo dire che borbey ti stimo e
dai più bello quello che ho fatto
evitare come ha fatto a certi questo
colore dal verde
anche io sono bravo non ho mica
accettato con glitter comunque
anticipate del menu back eccetera è
stato appena fatto è normale è certo del
successo che a monforte di che sarà
perfetto ma è il vincitore io team osimo
vitale vitale riportate nel sondaggio mi
raccomando è stato un mi piace se volete
vedere altre life challenge e ora vi
lasciamo con quattro cartellino su cui
cliccare fatto vedere i nostri altri
video casa su quella che preferite e
volere